captain Johnathan Hillstrand drops his  first pot wait set here see what happens  beautiful another year the world  spinning drops are spinning everything's  turning  calm out can't a better day for a fresh  season  helicopter spinning around me  no it's no now unless this is wrong time  but what do you have for time  that doesn't compute 11:20 that doesn't  know you  I thought it was noon and I got excited  and I had the guise of a pop I said her  early I don't know I did it I think I  hit her was off I had this other  computer that I've been he is they  thought of my watch was right dude it  was bad timing  Jonathan jump the gun landing him on the  wrong side of the law  okay mark here not any more gear Sam I  ski making baits up plug doesn't fly  back the ISIS  that's not good  Oh